الحرب اوكرانيه روسيه لكن العبره الصينيه
وتحديدا في مضيق تايوان دفعت بكين الى وضع
استراتيجياتها ازاء المضيق في ميزان
المراجعه واعاده التقييم
وفقا تقرير صادر عن صحيفه لوفيغو الفرنسيه
فانكسه الجيش الروسي غيرت النظره الثانيه
بخصوص الاستراتيجيه المتبعه اتجاه تايوان
فلوعي بالضعف العسكري لروسيا في الميدان
بات مصدر قلق متزايد لحليفها الصيني الذي
يتبنى وجهه نظر قاتمه للتوتر ويحاول تجنب
عدم تكرار الاخطاء المرتكبه في اوكرانيا
فصينا اليوم تسابق الزمن لتطوير امكانتها
التكنولوجيا وتوسيع قاعدتها الصناعيه
العسكريه اولويات ومساع جديده اختارتها
بكين في سياستها العسكريه الفنيه اساسها
تعلم واستعاب الدرس من الخسائر التي تعرض
لها روسيا في اوكرانيا وايضا اعاده النظر
في قدرات الجيش الصيني تحسبا لعمليه
عسكريه محتمله في تايوان حيث يعمل الجيش
الصيني على تحسين امكانته الاستخباراتيه
الهائله المخصصه للاستطلاع وتطوير قوه
الدعم الاستراتيجيه الصينيه بعد دراسه
التجربه القتاليه للجيش الروسي في المجال
البري والبحري والجوي وبالنظر لسوء
التنسيقي بين الوحدات العسكريه الروسيه
التي كانت منتشره في الشرق وجنوب اوكرانيا
عمدت الصين على اعاده ضبط هيكل جيشها ضمن
اطار تنظيم يضم انظمه الاتصالات
واستخبارات وتحكم المتطوره كما حاولت تجنب
الاخطاء ونقاط الضعف التي تم تحديدها
للجيش الروسي في مجال الاتصالات واستطلاع
الفضاء والطائرات بدون طيار ونقص الاسلحه
عاليه الدقه للمدفعيه
فمعظم الدروس التي استفادت منها الصين
تتعلق بشكل اساسي بالاقتصاد العسكري
والمعدات العسكريه وهنا باتت الاولويه
واضحه حيث تقوم بتطوير انواع مختلفه من
الطائرات بدون طيار وانتاج مجموعه واسعه
من قطاع المدفعيه الحديثه